- Let's say that you normally
go to bed at 10:00 PM,
and you wake up at 6:00 AM,
but tomorrow morning you've
got an early morning flight,
so you have to wake up at
4:00 AM rather than 6:00 AM.
How much sleep have you lost?
Well, you've lost two hours
of your eight hour night of
sleep, so you've lost 25%.
Yes and no.
You've lost 25% of
your total sleep,
but based on the structure of
sleep that we just described,
you may have lost 50, 60,
70% of all of your REM sleep,
all of your dream sleep.
So there are real implications
to understanding that.
(upbeat mellow music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a professor of
neuroscience and psychology
at the University of
California, Berkeley,
Director of the Center
for Human Sleep Science,
and host of "The
Matt Walker Podcast."
Dr. Matthew Walker, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Pleasure to be with you, Dave.
Thanks for having me.
- Well, I'm thrilled
that we're doing this
because as you know, we're
airing this in August,
but right now it's the last
couple of days of July.
I am on my 30 day digital and
really societal sabbatical,
and I'm going to work
on a lot of things,
diet, exercise, digital detox,
but also work on
some sleep stuff,
and that is your
area of expertise.
So I guess before I
ask you anything else,
how does one become
curious and enamored
and eventually live their life
to tell people about sleep
of all things?
- Yeah, I think myself,
like many of my colleagues,
we are all accidental
sleep researchers.
You know, I don't think
when we were kids,
and you were going
around the classroom,
and the teacher was
saying, you know,
"What would you like to
be when you grow up,"
no one was shooting
their hand and saying,
"I'd really love to be
a sleep researcher."
So I fell into it by accident
when I was doing my PhD.
I was studying different
types of dementia
and trying to diagnose
them very early on,
failing miserably,
and I realized I should
be measuring my patients
when they were asleep rather
than when they were awake
to measure their
brainwave activity.
Started doing that,
got some great results,
and realized, that
was 20 years ago,
realized that at the time,
no one could answer a
very simple question.
Why do we sleep?
And the best answer we had
back then was that we sleep
to cure sleepiness, which is
the factual equivalent.
- I guess that works.
- You know, that's like saying,
well, you eat to cure hunger.
No, you eat for a whole
plethora of different reasons.
Now, 20 years later, due to the
work of all of my colleagues
and we've done a
little bit too I hope,
we've had to upend the question.
We've had to ask,
is that any operation
of your brain,
and is there any physiological
system in your body
that isn't wonderfully
enhanced when you get sleep
or demonstrably impaired
when you don't get enough?
And so far the answer
seems to be no.
- Yeah. All right.
Well, there's a whole
bunch of questions
that I want to ask you
that are going to revolve
sort of around my sleep
habits and my nap habits
and this thing, what's
in this coffee cup,
but right now, which you
probably can guess...
- I'm so glad that you're
drinking decaffeinated.
(both laughing)
- I honestly don't
think I've ever.
- Au contraire.
- Yeah, I don't think
I've ever had decaf.
But before we get into any
of any of those specifics,
can you just talk to me
sort of broadly about sleep?
You know, we hear about
sort of like, you know,
the type of sleep that you're
having throughout the night.
What's the most important?
When are you getting the
most restorative stuff?
All that.
- Yeah, so sleep, at
least in human beings,
and in fact, in all
mammalian species,
is broadly separated
into two types.
We have non-rapid
eye movement sleep,
and then we have rapid
eye movement sleep.
And those two types
of sleep will play out
in this beautiful sort of
battle for brain domination
throughout the night.
And then the cerebral war
is going to be won and lost
between non-REM and
REM every 90 minutes.
And then it's just going to
be replayed every 90 minutes
to create your standard sort
of Dave Rubin sleep cycle.
What's different, however,
is the ratio of non-REM to REM
within those 90 minute cycles
as you move across the night.
So what I mean by that is
in the first half of last night,
the majority of your
90 minute cycles
were comprised of lots
of deep non-REM sleep
and very little REM sleep,
but as you push through to
the second half of the night,
that seesaw balance
actually shifts,
and now the majority of
those 90 minute cycles
is comprised much
more of REM sleep.
And REM sleep is the stage
that we typically
associate with dreaming.
And I mention this
sort of architecture,
not just because it's hopefully
intellectually interesting,
but it has implications.
So let's say that you normally,
I'm just going to make this up,
and we'll hopefully hear what
your actual sleep schedule is,
but let's say that you
normally go to bed at 10:00 PM,
and you wake up at 6:00 AM,
but tomorrow morning you've
got an early morning flight,
so you have to wake up at
4:00 AM rather than 6:00 AM.
How much sleep have you lost?
Well, you've lost two hours
of your eight hour
night of sleep,
so you've lost 25%.
Yes and no.
You've lost 25% of
your total sleep,
but based on the structure of
sleep that we just described,
you may have lost 50, 60,
70% of all of your REM sleep,
all of your dream sleep.
So there are real implications
to understanding that.
To your point though, which
one is more important,
all stages of sleep
are actually important.
Different stages of sleep
do different things for
your brain and your body
at different times of night,
but we need all of them.
You know, if, when
you think about sleep
as being such an
idiotic thing to do
from an evolutionary
perspective, you know,
if Mother Nature
could have said,
"Well, I'm going to take
these three stages of sleep,
and I'm just going to remove
them so he saves some time,"
and there's no harm
to the organism,
then she would have done it
hundreds, millions of years ago,
but all stages of sleep
have been preserved
throughout the
evolutionary path.
That means all of
them are important,
and that's exactly
what we're finding.
- So is eight hours,
is that the magic
number that everybody
sort of still seems to
think is like, you know,
for the average person,
eight hours is the number
that you want to get?
- There is a range.
So what we recommend right now
is somewhere between seven
to nine hours of sleep
is what the average
adult seems to require.
Once you get below seven,
we can typically
start to measure
impairments in your
brain and your body,
and you know, so much
so based on the evidence
that the number of people who
seem to be able to survive
on less than six hours of sleep
without showing any impairment
rounded to a whole number
and expressed as a
percent of the population
is actually zero.
- Interesting.
So I'll give you a little bit
of my personal part of this
on the eight hours.
When I started writing
my first book last year,
really over two years
ago at this point,
when I first started writing it,
I would find that I was
thinking about it so much
that I would go to sleep,
let's say somewhere between
like 11 and 12:00 PM,
or, you know,
midnight, basically,
I'd be thinking,
and then I'd wake up early
with the same thoughts
on my mind.
So I'd wake up at like 6:00 AM,
and then from 6:00 AM till
literally like 3:00 PM,
I could just write and write
and write, write, write, write,
and then it would be like,
man, I need a break right now.
And I started taking sort of
20 minute or half hour naps
around 3:00 PM, and I
still try to do that.
I can't always do it obviously,
but I try to do that.
And I'm curious, if you can
move some of it into a nap
later in the day, do you
need it continuously?
- That's a beautiful question.
So firstly, there
is some importance
about the continuity of sleep,
and what I mean by
that is at night,
for that six hours
that you were getting,
if it's very choppy sleep,
it's very sort of staccato,
and it's broken up,
and it's peppered with
lots of awakenings,
that's not good quality sleep.
But let's go back to your
example or your lived life,
which is, you know,
six hours of sleep
and then a nap during the day.
Is that okay?
I think the first thing to
note is that we human beings
may not have been
designed in the way
that most of us sleep right now,
which is what we call
monophasic sleep.
In other words, one long
single bout of sleep at night.
Because if I place
electrodes on your head,
sometime between the sort
of one to 4:00 PM mark,
for most people,
there is a drop in your
brain's level of alertness,
and it's pre-programmed.
It has nothing to do with
a big lunch, by the way.
Some people think that.
But you know, in the
afternoon in meetings
you can start to see those
ugly head bobs that sort of,
you know, it's a dead giveaway.
People falling prey.
- That's the three
o'clock feeling,
right?
- That's exactly.
- Didn't those
5-hour Energy people
made an awful lot of
money on this feeling?
- They certainly did indeed,
but it's genetically hardwired.
As I said, it's pre-programmed,
it happens to all of us.
What that means is that we
may not have been designed
as a species to sleep
in a monophasic pattern.
We may have been designed
to sleep in what we call
a biphasic pattern, which is
a long bout of sleep at night,
just as you're getting,
and then a short sort of siesta
like nap in the afternoon.
So I think that
that's perfectly fine.
In fact, we may be
designed to do that,
but naps are a
double-edged sword.
There is a dark side to
naps, and it's the following.
When you're awake
during the day,
you build up all of
this healthy sleepiness,
and it's a chemical
that builds up,
and it's been building up
in my brain and your brain
since the moment we
woke up this morning,
and it's called adenosine.
The more of it that builds
up, the sleepier you feel.
And then when you go
to sleep at night,
the brain gets the
chance to evacuate
all of that sleep pressure,
all of that adenosine.
So that after about eight hours,
you wake up feeling
refreshed and restored.
The problem with naps then
is that if you take
a nap that's too long
or too late in the
afternoon or in the evening,
it just takes the edge
off that sleepiness.
And it's a little bit like
a valve on a steam cooker.
You know, it just releases
some of that steam,
and so now it's harder
for you to fall asleep
and then stay asleep at night.
So it's a little bit like
snacking before your main meal.
So I think for you, I
would say if you are not
struggling with sleep at night
and you can nap
regularly during the day,
the naps of about 20 minutes,
sort of some time around,
stop before about 4:00 PM,
that's great.
But if you are struggling
with sleep at night,
then avoid naps during the day.
Build up all of that
healthy sleepiness.
- Have you done any research,
or do you know of anyone
that's done any research?
Sometimes what I'll
find is if I try
to just close my eyes for
20 minutes at three o'clock,
I don't necessarily fall asleep,
and it's actually pretty rare
that I would get
into a deep sleep,
but you know, I could be
in that quasi-sleep stage,
but sometimes it's more just,
I've just closed my eyes
and just try not to think
about anything major,
politics, the
craziness of the world,
and that in and of itself
is almost enough of a reset.
Have they done any
research on that,
that just the process
of just 20 minutes
with your eyes closed
and maybe just getting
into that initial phase
could be enough?
- Yeah, we have done
studies on that,
and that's exactly
what we're finding,
that even that quiet rest
where you have your eyes closed
and you're somewhat disengaged.
Now, if you look at
the brain itself,
it's actually dipping like
a little beak into water.
It's dipping itself and
having a little soupcon
of sort of sleep
during that time.
Most of that time, you're
not aware that you're asleep
because it's still
lighter stages of sleep,
but it can be restorative.
It can have benefits for
your mood, for your emotions,
even some benefits for
cardiovascular health.
Is it as potent as, you
know, getting into sleep?
No, it's not.
But is it better
than just constantly
trying to power through and
grabbing another cup of coffee
and you know, hope for the best?
Absolutely, it's much
better than that.
So it's all a range.
I think there's a gradient
of different conscious states
that our brain goes through,
and some of them can
really be beneficial.
It doesn't have to
all be about sleep.
- All right, so you
mentioned coffee.
I already showed
you the coffee cup.
I'm a coffee guy.
When I wake up in the morning,
the first thing that I think
about is that cup of coffee.
Sometimes I'm thinking about it
as I'm going to bed
the night before,
and I probably have a
second cup most days.
Am I doing something wrong here?
Am I overly
caffeinating my brain?
Am I harming my sleep?
Am I doing something too
unnatural to my normal rhythm?
- Based on what you just said,
you're not doing anything wrong.
And I would actually-
- All right.
- recommend drink coffee,
which sounds strange
from someone like me,
but when it comes to coffee,
just like with drugs,
the dose and the timing
makes the poison.
So first, there are some
wonderful health associations
with coffee, and that is, I
think, very strong evidence.
By the way, it has nothing to
do with the caffeine though,
that the principle reason
you get health associations
with the cup of coffee
is because the coffee
bean contains most
of the antioxidants
that people eat or consume
because our diets are not
particularly enriched,
the way that we eat in this
modern era, in antioxidants.
And it's left to
the coffee bean,
the humble coffee bean,
to carry the weight of most
people's antioxidant needs.
So a cup of coffee
or two cups of coffee
or even three cups of
coffee in the morning,
that's just fine.
Try to cut yourself off after
about midday for most people,
and here's the reason why.
Firstly, coffee or
caffeine has a half-life
of about five to six hours.
In other words, after
about five to six hours,
50% of that caffeine is
still in your system,
which means that caffeine
has a quarter-life
of 10 to 12 hours.
So if you have a cup
of coffee at midday,
it would be the
equivalent of you
getting into bed at midnight,
and before you
turn the light out,
you swig a quarter
of a cup of coffee
and you hope for
good night of sleep,
and it's probably
not going to happen.
But even if you're one of those
people who says, you know,
like, I can have an
espresso with dinner,
I fall asleep fine, and I stay
asleep, so no harm, no foul.
That's not quite true either
because a cup of
coffee in the evening
will decrease the amount
of deep sleep that you get,
deep non-REM sleep, by
somewhere between 20 to 30%.
Now, for me to take away that
amount of deep sleep from you,
I would probably have to
age you by about 15 years,
or you could just do it
every night with an espresso.
So I think, you know, I
want to be clear here.
I'm just a scientist,
and I'm not here to tell
anyone how to live their life.
That's not my job.
All I want to do is, you
know, give you the science
behind sleep and
things like caffeine
so that people can make
an informed choice.
You know, life is to be
lived to a certain degree.
- Yeah. So when you meet
the people who are like,
"Oh, you know, if I have a
cup of coffee after 4:00 PM,
I'm up all night"
versus the guy that can have
the double espresso at 11,
is that partly just
how they're wired?
I mean, is that just
their physiology?
- It is their physiology,
and in fact, it's the genes.
And we know these genes.
There are several
different genes,
and if you want to sort
of get a little bit nerdy,
it's called cytochrome P450,
and it determines the
speed of breakdown
of decomposition essentially
of the caffeine in your system.
Now, some people have a
version of that enzyme
where they will break down
the caffeine very quickly.
Other people, and
unfortunately, I'm one of them,
have a version of that enzyme
where the caffeine metabolism
is very, very slow.
So if I have a cup of
coffee at, you know,
9:00 AM in the morning
after waking up at 6:30
or seven in the morning,
even that usually leads to me
not having a great
night of sleep.
So there are
individual differences,
and we understand the
genetic basis of those.
- What about some of the
habits of good sleepers?
One of the things that
I've been trying to do
for the last couple of years,
probably about two years now,
is I try not to bring
my phone in the bedroom.
So I don't want the phone
to be the last thing
that I look at when my
head hits the pillow,
and I don't want it to be
the first thing that I see
when I wake up in the morning.
That's been pretty
helpful for me.
Do you guys recommend
certain habits,
or have you found
that certain people
just have better habits
related to actually getting
into that deep sleep?
- Yeah. I think you
mentioned a great one here,
which is the phone.
You know, the invasion of
technology into the bedroom
has been a harmful influence
on our sleep in the modern era.
And in a way though, you know,
that genie is out the bottle,
and it's not going
in any time soon.
So there's no point in
me necessarily saying,
you know, it's got to be a
technology free environment.
What I would say though,
is you've probably had
that experience where
you know that you need to get
up for an early morning flight
or there's something
that you have to do
ultra important
the next morning.
You know that that
night of sleep
is just not going to
be the best night.
And it's almost as though,
if you've got to wake up
at five in the morning
for your flight, you wake up
at 4:58 before your alarm.
- [Dave] Yep.
- And the reason is
because the brain,
it stays in this very
shallow form of sleep.
It's not very restorative sleep.
And it's a phenomenon that's
called anticipatory anxiety.
In other words, you know
something is upcoming,
and the brain goes into almost
this threat detection state
because of the anxiety,
and your sleep is shallow
for understandable reasons.
I mention this because
having your phone there
is a kind of diet
version of that.
You know, it's sort
of anxiety lite,
L, I, T, E, for the next day,
because you're right.
For most of us, and I've been
guilty of this in the past,
you know, the first
thing that we do
when we wake up in the
morning is reach across,
and we swipe right, and
we open up the phone,
and we know that there
is waiting for us,
just a tsunami of anxiety,
of emails, social media,
it all comes through.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And what that does is
that it trains your brain
to expect that type of anxiety
jag each and every morning.
And so when you go
to bed at night,
you're not going to have that
restorative restful sleep.
The other thing with technology
by the way in the evening
is that it causes what's
called sleep procrastination.
It's a real thing where, you
know, you're perfectly tired,
you could fall asleep,
but have your phone
there and you think,
oh, I should just check
Facebook one less time,
and I'm just going to
order that thing on Amazon,
and, you know, oh, Dave
Rubin had this great section.
I'm going to watch that.
And all of a sudden,
it's 20 minutes later,
and you do that each
and every night,
it's like compounding
interest on a loan,
and it can really
degrade your sleep.
So I would say
the rule of thumb,
if you want to
try and hack that,
is you could only use
your phone in the bedroom
when you're standing up.
And after about five
minutes of doing that,
as soon as you sit down
or you want to lie down,
that's the time you got
to put the phone away.
- Yeah, so you mentioned
the compounding interest
part of this, so when
people are in those phases,
when you're just not getting
that good enough sleep,
you're too busy,
life's crazy, anxiety,
whatever it might be,
what is the compounding
effects of that?
What are those effects?
- They are non trivial.
I think, you know, we
used to think of sleep
as the third pillar
of good health,
alongside diet and exercise.
Now, in fact, I was wrong
when I used to say that.
It is actually the foundation
on which those two
of the things sit,
that's how essential it is.
And that's the reason that
we've now been finding
significant links and
some of them causal
between short sleep duration
and things such as
Alzheimer's disease,
depression,
cardiovascular disease,
obesity, stroke, diabetes,
numerous psychiatric
conditions as well.
And so I think what this
tells us is that sleep is,
it's not really an
optional lifestyle luxury.
It is a non-negotiable
biological necessity.
And if you use that sweet spot
of seven to nine hours a night,
there is an unfortunate
simple truth
that the shorter your sleep,
the shorter your life.
Short sleep predicts
all cause mortality.
It is the elixir of life.
You know, it's the Swiss Army
Knife of health as it were.
- So as a scientist,
I am sure you're
around scientists
who would love to figure
out ways to make us operate
at higher levels
with less sleep,
to be, you know,
"more productive,"
whether that is true or not,
or I suppose it would depend on
your definition of productive,
but is there research
in that regard?
Like, you know, if I could
get five more hours in a day,
just think about all the
things that I could do
in those five hours?
- Yeah, and the way
that sleep science
has taught a lesson
around this question
is a slightly different view.
The longer that you're awake...
So firstly, what we know
is that after a human being
has being awake for about
20 or 21 hours straight,
you are as cognitively
impaired as you would be
if you were legally drunk,
which surprises me
that in the workplace,
not all workplaces,
but commonly, you know,
it's almost this sort of sleep
machismo attitude sometimes
where we're quite braggadocio
of how little sleep
that we're getting in,
and employers will
sometimes co-opt
and encourage that kind of
behavior from the employees.
And what's funny to me is
that no employer would say,
"Gosh, I've got this great
team I'm working with.
They're drunk all the time,"
you know.
(Dave laughing)
But that's the
situation when your team
is trying to survive on
insufficient sleep in a way.
So rather than answering your
question in the sense of,
can we...
Although I do have
several ideas and desires
to try to do what you're saying,
which is, can I compress sleep,
can I kind of, you know,
the analogy would be, can I
create a zip file for sleep?
Can I shrink down the time,
and we get everything
that we need in less time?
I think that that's a fool
hearty way of doing it though,
because when you are well-slept,
you are just much
more effective,
and you are much more efficient.
So to answer your question,
if you want to get back
those five hours of your day,
don't think of sleep as a cost.
Think of sleep as an
investment in tomorrow
because when you are well slept,
it's a little bit like cooking.
Why would you try to boil a
pot of water on medium heat
when you could do it in
half the time on high?
That is the consequence
of a good night of sleep.
And so sometimes people say,
"Look, the reason I can't get
my seven to nine hours of sleep
is that I'm just so busy."
And my response is sometimes,
"Well, it may be that
you've got so much to do
or so much left to do because
you're not well-slept.
And if you were well-slept,
your efficiency would increase,
and you wouldn't have that
much left on your plate.
That's what the science
is actually teaching us."
- Where do things like the
pillow and the mattress
and the temperature and
all that kind of stuff
fit into this?
Because I know just from
YouTube and online life,
almost every ad these
days is about a new pillow
that's going to fix
all your sleep problems
or a new mattress or
some other, you know,
this new sheet has a
special thing in it
that will keep you
cool if you're hot
or keep you hot if you're cool
or just some other of that.
There seems to be like a
real obsession with this now.
- Yeah, and I don't mind
the obsession so much
because in some ways it
draws attention to this.
You know, sleep has been
the neglected stepsister
in the health
conversation of today
for the past 10, 20 years.
So that's okay,
but, you know, there's a little
bit of snake oil out there,
for sure.
We don't have much data on
the effectiveness of pillows.
Mattresses, there is some data,
and mattresses are tough
because it's very individualized
based on your weight,
your anatomical structure,
are you in pain in terms
of your back, are you not,
are you in pain for your neck?
And I do like, I mean, the
mattress is an interesting
vehicle for sleep researchers
because when you think about
the car that you drive today
versus the car that
you were driving maybe,
or could have
bought 20 years ago,
from a technology standpoint,
they are radically different.
Nowadays your car is
packed full of sensors
that measure just
about everything.
Think about your
mattress, though.
You know, your mattress
today is much more similar
to your mattress
of 20 years ago.
Why is that the case?
Because we spend, you know,
hopefully seven to nine hours
of sleep on our mattress.
I very much hope that
most people don't spend
that much time...
Maybe they spend two hours
a day in the car at maximum.
So yet we're happy to invest
tens of thousands of dollars
in our car, which we
spend less time in,
and we haven't got there
yet with mattresses.
So I think mattresses have
an untapped potential,
and there are a number
of companies now
that are doing this.
The final thing you
mentioned is temperature.
This is definitely one of
the things that you can use
to help manipulate your sleep.
It turns out that your
brain and your body
need to drop the
core temperature
by about two to three
degrees Fahrenheit,
or about one degree Celsius,
in order for you to fall asleep
and then stay asleep
soundly across the night.
And it's the reason you
will always find it easier
to fall asleep in a room
that's too cold than too hot.
So what we've been
finding is that
if you can use the mattress
or just make sure
that your bedroom,
the ambient temperature
is set appropriately.
And when I say appropriately,
for the average adult,
it's somewhere between 65
to 67 degrees Fahrenheit,
which I know sounds cold,
but cold it must be.
If we can get there, usually
better sleep unfolds.
- Yeah. I mean, I'm completely
with you on that one.
We usually do probably like 68,
which is close
enough to that range.
I mean, it's pretty
chilly in that room,
and that's the number
'cause there's nothing
worse than waking up
in the middle of the night and
you're hot and sweaty and...
- Oh yeah, it's a disaster.
And that changes
your sleep cycles
and the quality of your
sleep as well, temperature.
- All right, let's
talk about marijuana.
Where does marijuana fit
into the equation here?
Because every now and
again, not that often,
I take basically like a puff
or two once or twice a week,
but it's only at night
when I know I'm going
to fall asleep soon.
So I got "Seinfeld" on, and
I'm laying on the couch,
and it's like one puff,
and then once I feel the
eyes go heavy, I go to bed.
That's what I try to do.
Every now and again, I
pass out on the couch,
but what do you
think about marijuana
when it comes to sleep?
- I love it.
"Seinfeld" and a
bit of marijuana
is sort of the day Rubin
prescription for good sleep.
- There might've been a
glass of red wine in there,
which I'll ask you about
that one, too, or you can
just take it away from there.
- Yeah, we'll come onto that.
Yeah, but you'll have
to send me that T-shirt.
So unfortunately,
it's not great news
when it comes to marijuana,
but I want to
separate THC from CBD.
So cannabis has a composition
of many different compounds.
THC or tetrahydrocannabinol
is the psychoactive
component of cannabis.
That's the thing that
gets people high.
CBD is different.
It is the non-psychoactive
component.
What we found is
that cannabis use,
it can speed the time with
which you fall asleep.
It's speeding up that.
So in other words,
it takes you a shorter amount
of time to fall asleep,
but there are two problems
with cannabis use and sleep.
Firstly, you develop
a dependency,
and it develops quite quickly.
And then when you stop,
typically what you do is have
terrible rebound insomnia,
and you have to jump back
on the bandwagon again
of cannabis use.
The second issue with THC
is that it's very good
at disrupting and
suppressing your REM sleep,
your dream sleep.
And REM sleep, dream sleep
is associated with things
such as your emotional
and mental health,
things such as creativity
and memory benefits.
Even your lifespan
is predicted by
the amount of REM
sleep that you get.
It's also are critical
for hormonal regulation,
testosterone in
men, for example.
So you really don't want to
have anything that disrupts
your REM sleep, but
THC will do that.
So I'm really not...
You know, again, I feel
when it comes to coffee,
and I'm going to make
things even worse for myself
when it comes to alcohol,
but I'm a desperately
unpopular person
by both nationality
and personality,
but when I start
offering these things,
I'm even less sort
of interesting.
So THC, I would
stay away from it.
CBD, however, and we don't
have enough data yet,
nowhere near enough data
to say anything definitive,
but it looks interesting.
I think what we can say
about CBD so far is that
it at least doesn't
harm your sleep.
There are some signs that
it could help your sleep.
And I think there are
a number of routes,
biological routes,
that are tenable
through which CBD could
act as a sleep promoter.
The first is that CBD alters
your body temperature,
and it will produce a state
of increased hypothermia.
In other words, it will
help cool you down.
The second thing is that THC,
and are some great studies now
demonstrating that
it's a very strong
what we call anxiolytic,
meaning it makes you
feel less anxious.
If you can cool the body down,
and you can switch
the body away from
the fight or flight branch
of the nervous system,
in other words, the anxious
branch of the nervous system,
then you are well on
your way to better sleep.
So I can see why there are at
least two parsimonious reasons
why CBD could have a benefit.
Do we have the data yet
where someone like me would feel
comfortable advocating that?
Not right now.
The only thing I would note
is that the evidence suggests
CBD is interesting in its curve.
And what I mean by
that is at low doses,
CBD may actually
be wake promoting
and force you awake and
make your sleep worse.
But at higher doses, it
seems to be more soporific
in that sense.
Again, we don't have the data,
I am not a medical doctor,
and none of this is
prescriptive advice.
It's just the science
that we have so far.
But I would say that
people should just be
a little bit mindful here.
Again, the dose
can make the poison
when it comes to sleep perhaps.
- All right, now the
wine part of this,
or we can answer this
with all alcohol,
but wine, we've
all sat at a table
with someone who's
drinking wine,
and at some point, they're
basically falling asleep
at the table, so how could
that not be good for sleep?
- Yeah, so alcohol is
not great for sleep
in three different ways.
Firstly, alcohol is
in a class of drugs
that we call the sedatives.
And sedation is not sleep,
but when you have a couple
of drinks in the evening,
and you think, "Well, I
fell asleep more quickly,"
you're mistaking
sedation for sleep,
and then not the same thing.
If I were to show you your
electrical brainwave activity
when you've had a couple
of drinks in the evening
during sleep versus
natural sleep,
they're not the same thing.
The second problem with alcohol
is that it fragments your sleep,
so you wake up many more
times throughout the night.
Now the problem here is that
you will typically not
remember waking up.
So the next morning maybe
you don't feel restored
or refreshed by your sleep,
but you think, "Well, you
know, I fell asleep quickly,
and I don't remember waking up,
so it's not the alcohol,"
but it definitely will
just litter your sleep
with these awakenings.
The final problem with alcohol
is that, similar to THC,
but through a very
different mechanism,
alcohol will also
block your dream sleep.
So, you know, again,
I'm not trying to tell
anyone what they should do,
and you know, again,
live life to a full
because I've heard that
we're dead a long time.
But you know, if I were to give
politically incorrect
advice, you know,
if it's just you and me now
talking, Dave, and no one-
- Just us.
Just us, don't worry.
- No one's listening.
The best advice I would have is
go to the pub in the morning,
and that way the alcohol
is out of your system
in the evening, and
there's no worry at all.
But I would never say
that publicly on a show.
- Got it.
So you go to the
pub in the morning,
so you can take that 3:00 PM,
although I guess it's not
quite the nap that you want,
you're getting more
of the other thing.
- Right, stick it out,
last it through,
and then you'll probably be
washed out by the evening.
- So where does diet
fit into all of this
'cause I think we've all
had different moments
where, you know, you eat
a real rich, heavy meal
and suddenly you're not
necessarily sleeping well,
you're maybe getting some
indigestion, some heartburn,
that kind of stuff?
That obviously
doesn't help sleep,
but I'm sure there's
some other foods
that probably aid sleep and
foods that probably harm sleep.
- There's definitely
a bi-directional
relationship for sure.
Firstly, what we know
is that eating to excess
in the evening and also eating
a diet that is high in sugar
and low in fiber,
both of those things
have been associated
with significantly
worse sleep quantity
and significantly
worse sleep quality.
There is a bit of a myth
though around this, you know,
you need to stop eating after
four hours or three hours.
What we found is that you can go
as close as 60
minutes before bed
and food doesn't seem
to be a significant
disruptor of sleep.
Now, after that, once you
get too close to sleep,
then it does have a blast radius
where it can be
detrimental to your sleep.
There are certain different
sort of food types
that may enhance sleep,
and this comes on to sort of
some of the supplement world.
And I'm a hard nosed scientist,
and again, I don't
advocate for supplements,
but it's interesting.
I've been doing a lot of
sort of reading and research
around the supplement space,
you know, and there's
some fascinating work
on things like
tart cherry juice.
You know, I was thinking
this is nonsense,
and I was ready to read the
papers and rip them apart,
the scientific data,
but paper after paper
from some very
well-respected scientists
seem to show that
it had a benefit.
Even kiwifruit seemed
to have a benefit.
Now, why is this the case
for some of these studies?
I don't think it's
because there's anything
necessarily magical about them.
It's that they are
high in antioxidants,
and what we found is that when
you administer antioxidants,
it has a beneficial
effect on sleep.
And so when you're getting
your sufficient supply
of those key ingredients,
it seems to communicate
a signal to your brain
for better sleep at night.
But overall, I think when
it comes to diet, you know,
staying away...
Well, a diet that's high
in sugar and low in fiber
is pretty much bad for
just about anything,
but it turns out sleep is
part of that problem too.
And it works both
ways, by the way.
If you're not getting
sufficient sleep,
you will gain more weight,
and there are a number
of reasons for this.
Firstly, your appetite
regulating hormones
go in very bad directions
when you're not getting
sufficient sleep.
So you won't feel satisfied
by what you're eating,
and you'll want to eat more
because you're
constantly hungry.
It's basically the sleep
deprivation induced munchies.
And it's not just
those hormones.
Coming back to cannabis,
your body produces its own
version of those cannabinoids.
They're called endocannabinoids.
And most people have
sort of had or heard,
I'm sure you have
not experienced,
but when you have a little
too much just to smoke,
you get the munchies.
- Once.
- Yeah, and you start just
wanting to consume everything
because these cannabinoids
increase your appetite.
They increase your
desire to eat.
Well, when you are under slept,
when you're sleep deprived,
your body increases its own
production of endocannabinoids.
That's part of the reason
why you start to feel
so much more hungry when
you are sleep deprived
and why you will eat
somewhere between
two to 400 extra
calories each day
when you're not getting
sufficient sleep.
- Wow, that's
really interesting.
Let's wrap up with dreams
because this will be my
fifth August off the grid,
and one of the things
that I've noticed is,
because I try to work
on exercise and diet
and sleeping better and
just general digital detox
and relaxation,
I've noticed in the
four previous years
that I've done this
that my dreams are more
vivid during that time.
Maybe it's from being less
distracted or something.
So just broadly,
what the hell is going
on when we're dreaming,
and what can we
do to, I suppose,
maybe gain more
insight from our dreams
or something to that effect?
- Yeah, and actually I have
a quick question for you.
So when you're doing the detox,
will your sleep schedule change
where you may start to go
to bed a little bit later
and wake up a little bit later?
- No. I'll be going
to bed earlier usually
because I'm not doing
as much during the day.
So, you know, for
a portion of this,
and perhaps right now
as this is being aired,
I'm hoping that
I'm on the beach,
and it's a nice
bright, sunny day,
and I'm under a umbrella,
and it's about 3:00 PM,
and I'm napping.
That would be nice.
But then, you know, after
a day out on the beach,
by nine o'clock, there's a good
chance I could be sleeping.
And then I'm still,
regardless of when I
go to sleep at night,
I'm an early riser.
That definitely is
something new to me
the last couple of years of
my life, where it's like...
And maybe that's
partly sunshine in LA.
You know, it's sunny here
usually at about six or 6:30 AM,
and I'm usually just kind of
ready to go at that point,
but I probably will get a
significant amount more of sleep
in the course of
these 30 days or so.
- Got it.
So firstly, to stick a pin
in the daylight component,
daylight will absolutely
regulate your sleep timing,
and you can use it on both ends.
If you get too much light
exposure in the evening,
then it will block a
hormone called melatonin,
which is critical to
signal to your brain
it's nighttime, and
it's time to sleep.
And so when we have too
much electric lights,
or we're using our
computers at night,
it stamps the
brakes on melatonin,
and that's why some
people can struggle
with their at night.
So try to dim down half
of the lights in your home
in the last hour before sleep.
And then you can
reverse engineer the
trick in the morning.
Get lots of daylight.
You know, LA is a
great place to do that.
And it enlivens
you because it now,
sort of that daylight
will apply once again
the brakes on melatonin, and
it will help you wake up.
But coming back to dreams
and the function of dreams,
dreams seem to, or REM
sleep dreaming at least,
seems to provide at least
two different benefits.
The first is creativity.
What we found is that
it's during dream sleep
when the brain takes
all of the information
that it's been learning,
and it starts to
fuse it together
in creative and innovative ways.
You know, it's almost like
an informational alchemy.
And so we go to sleep with
the pieces of the jigsaw,
but we wake up with
the puzzle complete,
and that's one of the
creative benefits of sleep.
And there's a reason that
no one has ever told you
to stay awake on a problem.
(Dave laughing)
And there's a very
good scientific basis
for exactly that.
The second interesting
thing that we've discovered,
and we've done quite a
lot of work in this area,
is that REM sleep
dreaming provides
a form of emotional first aid,
and you can think of dreaming
as overnight therapy.
And REM sleep dreams will take
those difficult experiences,
sometimes even
traumatic experiences
that you've been having,
and it acts like a
nocturnal soothing balm,
and it just takes
the sharp edges off
those painful,
difficult experiences
so that you come
back the next day,
and they don't feel
as painful anymore.
And so I think in
that sense, dreaming,
you can think of it as,
well, it's not time
that heals all wounds,
it's time during dream
sleep that provides
emotional convalescence.
And those are the two functions
that we've been
strongly associating
with REM sleep dreaming.
- What about people that
don't remember their dreams?
I always find it so odd
because I really do
remember my dreams.
Every now and again,
I'll have a notepad
by the side of my bed,
and I'll scribble something
down that I want to remember
for the next morning,
something like that.
And I do find that
there are insights,
and I can piece
together something
that maybe I couldn't
have otherwise.
What about people that just
have no memory of their dreams?
You hear about that
every now and again?
- Yeah, it's not infrequent.
It's not necessarily
pathological.
It's not something that
you have to worry about
or go and see your doctor about.
We don't truly
understand why there are
those individual differences.
We certainly know
that they are present,
but we also know that
those people who say,
"Look, I just don't dream,"
it's not really that
you don't dream,
as you said, it's that you
don't remember your dreams
because if I bring those
people into my sleep center
here at University of
California, Berkeley,
and we can clearly see that
they're going into dream sleep.
And in fact, if I
go into the bedroom
when they're in a
REM sleep phase,
and I wake them up, and I say,
"Can you just tell me what
was going through your mind
before I woke you up?'
They will say, "It's
the strangest thing.
I was having a dream
for the first time."
It's just that when they
wake up in the morning,
that memory seems to
evaporate too quickly,
and it doesn't seem
to be committed
to conscious memory
recollection.
Does it mean that that
memory isn't there at all?
I actually don't think
that that's true.
I think it's quite
possible that we remember
much more of our dreaming lives
than we are consciously aware of
or that we have conscious
accessibility to.
But what we know from brain
science is that implicit memory,
information that you're
not consciously aware of,
can still profoundly
change your decisions
and your actions
and your behaviors.
So it leads to a
wacky hypothesis that
in fact, you know, much
more of our waking life
is determined by our
imprinted dream life,
but we just don't have conscious
access to that dreaming.
And I say that
because, you know,
I'm sure you've had
that experience too,
where you wake up and you
think, "I was dreaming.
What was that dream?"
- [Dave] What was that? Yeah.
- And it's just gone.
And then two days
later, you know,
you getting into your car,
and you see the key chain,
and it instantly
triggers the unlocking
of the memory of that dream.
In other words, that
memory was always there.
You'd lost the IP
address to go and find it
for conscious recollection.
And if it's still there,
it could still be
changing your behavior.
- All right, I said the
dreams was the last question,
but I'll give myself one
bonus question here, which is,
do you have one
other tip or trick
that I can incorporate
into this month
so that I come back as
well-rested and ready to go
and be back in the crazy
political and cultural fight
that I find myself in 11
months out of the year?
- You are a brave, brave
man, knowing what you do,
and I admire it greatly.
I am far too thin skinned
to be doing what you do.
- You are definitely
a wiser man, so.
- Let's not rush to judgment.
I probably, in the
past 45 minutes,
have just proven that
to be wrong as well,
but I will give you
one conventional tip
and one unconventional tip.
- Great.
- The first conventional
tip is regularity.
If I could give you one
single thing to start doing,
go to bed at the same time,
wake up at the same time,
no matter whether it's the
weekday or the weekend,
and regularity is king.
And the reason, because I
don't think people respond
to rules that are
just barked at them,
they respond to the
reasons, not the rules.
And the reason is this,
that your brain has
its own 24 hour clock,
and it responds best to sort of
the recognition of regularity.
So when it's getting regularity,
it's going to anchor your sleep,
and as I said,
improve the quantity
and the quality of that sleep.
So aim for regularity no
matter what day it is.
In terms of an
unconventional tip,
and this may sound a
little bit strange,
but if you have a bad night of
sleep, and everyone has them,
you know, I am not immune
just because I know a
little bit about sleep.
I have got my big
share of bad nights,
and I've had my own
bouts of insomnia
that I've battled
and struggled with.
But after a bad night of
sleep, people will say,
"What should I do?"
And my answer is do nothing.
And what I mean by that is
don't wake up any later,
don't drink any more
coffee the next day,
don't nap during that day,
and don't go to bed any earlier
than you would otherwise.
Do nothing.
Just stay the course and
repeat the same behavior.
Because if you wake up later,
then you're not
going to build up
enough of that sleep
pressure that we spoke about
for you to fall asleep
at your normal time
because you slept in later.
And second, if you
go to bed too early,
because you think
last night was so bad,
I should get to bed early,
your body is not expecting to
sleep at that different time,
that new earlier time,
so you're just going
to lie in bed awake,
tossing and turning, and
it's going to be even worse.
And then obviously,
caffeine and naps
we've spoken about too.
So the best
unconventional advice
if you've had a bad night
of sleep, is do nothing.
Stick to your routine.
- Matt, this was a
little unconventional
for my type of show, but
I thoroughly enjoyed it.
This is exactly
what I wanted to do
right before I
went off the grid,
and I hope that
everyone watching
is going to do a little
bit of this in August,
if no other month.
You know, I always do my
off the grid thing in August
because I feel like
it's end of the summer,
if there's ever
a time for anyone
to get their life
in order, that's it,
and then hopefully
you can incorporate it
into those other 11 months.
I really enjoyed talking to you,
and I appreciate
you doing the show.
- Thank you so
much for having me.
Take care and good
luck with August.
- Thanks.
If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.